lo que voy a intentar hacer en este
vídeo es calcular el valor de seno de 7
piso b 12 sin usar calculadora para
empezar visualicemos 7 piso sobre 12 en
el círculo unitario
el rayo inicial se ubica sobre la parte
positiva del eje x xi aquí tenemos que
esto es y medios que equivale a 6 y
sobre 12
así es que tomamos un doceavo de pi más
para obtener el ángulo de 7 pido sea voz
este es el ángulo que nos piden este es
el ángulo de 7 pi doceavos radiales y el
seno de este ángulo por la definición
del círculo unitario corresponde a la
coordenada en donde este radio de
longitud 1 es el círculo unitario
intersecta precisamente con el círculo
de tal manera que el seno de este ángulo
es exactamente la longitud de este de
este segmento de este segmento que estoy
dibujando aquí en magenta y te invito a
que pongas pausa el vídeo e intentes
usar todas tus capacidades de
trigonometría para calcular el seno de 7
pidos ya vos básicamente la longitud de
este segmento en magenta
supongo que ya lo intentaste y si
pensaste lo mismo que yo pensaste en
este pequeño ángulo que voy a dibujar
aquí déjame dibujarlo claramente este
sería el lado magenta que nos interesa
este día el lado magenta aquí tendríamos
la hipotenusa esté la hipotenusa que
sabemos que vale 1 este sería el ángulo
recto y aquí tendríamos este ángulo lo
conocemos este ángulo ya sabemos que
todo este ángulo es 6 pido si a vos por
lo cual este es p sobre 12 y sobre 12 no
pi sobre 16 así es que podemos usar
nuestras funciones trigonométricas para
encontrar este cateto adyacente a pi
sobre 12 recordamos que la función
coseno nos puede servir el coseno de un
ángulo es el cateto adyacente sobre la
hipotenusa de tal manera que aquí el
coseno depp y sobre 12 es este lado en
magenta sobre uno o equivalente mente
este lado en magenta mide coseno de pi
sobre 12 hemos encontrado que el seno de
7 piso b 12 es lo mismo que el coseno de
pi sobre 12 pero eso no me ayuda como
voy a encontrar el coche no x sobre 12
sin una calculadora así es que en vez de
pensarlo de esta manera veamos si
podemos descomponer este ángulo en un
par de ángulos de los cuales conozcamos
senos y cosenos y cuáles son esos
los ángulos especiales de los triángulos
rectángulos por ejemplo estamos
familiarizados con el triángulo 30 60 90
el triángulo 30 60 90 que es más o menos
así y esto es lo mejor que me sale a
mano aquí lo tenemos lo necesitamos en
radiales este ángulo en vez de 30 grados
lo ponemos como y sextos radiales este
ángulo de aquí es de pi tercios radiales
y este por supuesto es el ángulo recto
la hipotenusa mide 1 el cateto opuesto y
sextos que es el cateto más pequeño mide
la mitad de la hipotenusa esto es me de
un medio mientras que el cateto mayor
que es el opuesto pi tercios mide raíz
de tres veces el cateto menor es decir
mide raíz de tres sobre dos ya hemos
usado estos triángulos anteriormente
para calcular sen y cosenos de treinta y
sesenta grados ahora los vamos a usar
para calcular sean y coseno de pi
tercios y pi sextos radiales también
conocemos el triángulo 45 45 90 es un
triángulo rectángulo
isósceles
es un triángulo rectángulo isósceles no
esté este no me parece isósceles déjame
déjame extender un poco más aquí la
hipotenusa para que si sea isósceles ahí
está más o menos ahí está un triángulo
rectángulo y sociales cuya hipotenusa
mide 1 y el valor de los catetos es raíz
de 2 sobre 2 el valor de la hipotenusa
que en este caso es raíz de dos sobre 2
en vez de denominar los ángulos con 45
grados sabemos que esto equivale a pi
sobre 4 y sobre 4 radiales así es que si
tenemos ángulos de y sextos pi tercios o
pi cuartos puede usar estos triángulos
ya sea usando la definición clásica de
soca tohá o usando el círculo unitario
para establecer cuál es el seno el
coseno e inclusive la tangente de estos
ángulos pero entonces cómo puede
descomponer 7 pi 2 ya bosch como una
combinación de pi sextos pi tercios o pi
cuartos para ver esto vamos a escribir y
sextos pi tercios y pi cuartos usando 12
como denominador
tenemos que y sextos
es igual a 2 y 12 a 2 mientras que peter
cios es igual a 4 p 12 a 2 y finalmente
pi cuartos y cuartos es igual a 32 ya
vos ahora veamos dos más cuatro no es 72
397 pero 43 77 así es que puede usar
este y este 4 pisos ya vos +3 pido si a
vos es igual a 7 pido si a vos esto lo
puede escribir como esto es igual a seno
de 3 pido si a vos
+ 4 y 12 años lo cual es igual
a seno de ti cuartos lo voy a poner con
otro color y cuartos más seno de cuatro
pisos ya bosque es pi tercios
y tercios y ahora podemos usar la
fórmula para el seno de una suma de
ángulos la cual nos permite expresar
esto como la suma de productos de senos
y cosenos de estos ángulos hagamos
entonces eso esto es igual a esto es
igual a el seno
el seno
de cuartos que multiplica al coseno de
peters josh que multiplica al coseno de
peter cios más ahora intercambiamos
coseno de pi cuartos que multiplica a el
seno de pi tercios ahora nada más
tenemos que calcular estos valores y
aquí ya tenemos los triángulos para
hacerlo así es que el seno de pi cuartos
el seno de pi cuartos aquí lo podemos
calcular es el cateto opuesto entre la
hipotenusa el cateto opuesto aquí lo
tenemos mide raíz de 2 sobre 2 la
hipotenusa vale 1 así es que el seno de
pi cuartos es raíz de 2 sobre 2 kos en
oep y tercio este es el ángulo epi
tercios y cose no es cateto adyacente
sobre hipotenusa con lo cual cosen epi
tercios es un medio sobre 1 esto vale un
medio vámonos al otro término coseno pi
cuartos regresamos a este triángulo es
cateto adyacente sobre hipotenusa que
raíz de 2 sobre 2 sobre 1
así es que esto es raíz de 2 sobre 2 que
multiplica al seno de pi tercios que es
cateto opuesto raíz de 3 sobre 2 sobre
hipotenusa que vale 1 con lo cual se nos
peter si os vale raíz d
sobre 2 ahora lo único que tenemos que
hacer es simplificar esto veamos esto es
igual a raíz de 2 sobre dos por un medio
esto lo podemos escribir como raíz de
dos sobre dos por dos es cuatro por más
perdón más raíz de dos sobre dos por
raíz de tres sobre dos esto lo podemos
escribir como raíz de seis sobre cuatro
vamos a hacer esta suma
y aquí nos merecemos definitivamente una
fanfarria para hacer la suma tenemos el
mismo denominador
así es que simplemente sumamos los
numeradores esto es igual entonces a
raíz de dos más raíz de seis todo eso
todo eso dividido entre cuatro ese es el
valor de seno de siete pisos sobre 12
que también corresponde al valor de
coseno de pi sobre 12 este es el valor
pedido